all right guys
bang bang i've got felix here with me
thank you so much for doing this hey man
thanks for having me
of course let's just jump right into
your background what did you do before
crypto
yeah so i mean i've been a trader since
2012 um back then was like equities
derivatives
i did my first bitcoin analysis in like
2014 back then i had some
buddies in college that were you know
like tell me about this new thing
bitcoin they were trading you know
during the whole montgox hype
and i did my first analysis there i
didn't think much of it you know i did i
researched it and back then almost
anything could find it was like
exchanges getting hacked
and i was like there's a good chance
like i can make money but i will never
be able to see that money again so
i kind of kept my hands of it i really
dove into it when i became a ceo of a
crowdfunding company
and we were the first to integrate with
coinbase and bitpay so this was like
2015 2016
where i like regular back and forth like
coinbase bitpay because we're pretty
much
this was when the jobs act came through
where you were able to do equity
crowdfunding for the first time with
normal people
and we had kind of like a dual model
where we were both like kind of a
kickstarter but also equity crowdfunding
and we wanted to accept bitcoin because
there was
a lot of like south americans that
reached out to us like hey we love this
stuff
if we can use bitcoin um so and that put
crypto on my kind of radar on my front
and center and i delved more into it
started like you know watching andre's
tinoblus stuff and i just you know fell
down the rabbit hole like everybody
that kind of coincided with when my
co-founder started like suing each other
they like didn't get along there's some
money issues or whatever
and then i was like well you know here
you're on the sinking ship and then
there's this
new asset that it's just like probably
going to change the world and it's just
like so mind-bending the more i would
look into it
and by that point it was already like
early 2017 and i said you know what
let me get off the chump let me jump off
the sinking ship and go
all in on crypto let me take that risk
so i went all in on crypto early 2017
um you know started as a full-time
trader um because
i had some trading experience from
equities and derivatives beforehand
and you know like many did really well
in 2017 but unlike most i didn't pack my
bags i said hey there's so much more
here this isn't over
this is a time when i want to double
down instead of leaving the industry
yeah and so what did you do to double
down when you uh when you decided that
yeah so so 2018 i made two decisions one
i said hey i wanted to get out of my
hometown so to say and go somewhere i
can network better which was la at the
time so
because back then there was a lot of
stuff happening in la you know for
better wars eos was happening mostly in
la
you know there was like spanx j and
there was um i repeated it just a good
ecosystem at the time
and then secondly i launched my first
hedge fund um
so the way that happened essentially i
had a consulting client
that wanted blockchain advisory which i
was deep in at the time already
and i sat down the phone was a
multi-billionaire and he told me hey why
don't
you like trade for me we can start with
like 10 million and you know at the time
i was like 21 years old
and i was like oh [ __ ] you know that
kind of money exists that's out there
that wants to get into the market
you're silly not to say yes because
before i had like friends and family say
hey let me give you 20 000 and i was
like no i don't i don't want to deal
with the risk and you know all the
paper work that comes with it but i was
like 10 million you're being stupid
next day call it like you know google
how to start a hedge fund you know and i
find some attorney numbers call them up
get that consultation
net first guy i liked sent in the wire
and off the road we were
um sounded a lot easier than it was um
there was a lot more that came i'm sorry
um and yeah so that's kind of how it
started and i said you know
this is a time where i will be building
the infrastructure for the next five
years the next 10 years
so because ultimately i always think
that in the bull market kind of rip the
fruits in the bear markets that's when
you really need to sow the seeds just
like you did you know with the podcasts
and newsletters and everything
because you know we're all seeing this
parabolic growth now but that comes from
like you know the hundreds of days we
put in
yeah to plant the seeds and where did
you come from before you went to la um
well i was born and raised in germany so
i was born and raised in germany and it
was kind of
interesting too because i got immigrated
in 08 which was the financial crisis
so i really only got to know america in
this turnover so to say you know i'm
used
like the america i got to know was where
these strip malls turned to ghost malls
where you'd go to strip mall one day and
then you go there two months later and
half the stores are gone
right i mean i remember moving there we
had like linens and things was something
where we get like our bathware
and whatever that was gone chain went
bankrupt you know blockbuster was still
around went bankrupt my first bank
bachovia
acquired by wells fargo um so you know
that was like
just such an interesting like first
experience of that you know
the financial system isn't that stable i
think it very much had an impact on
me being a bitcoiner and crypt i mean
beyond i start as a bitcoin i'm very
open-minded
um so i i impress all digital assets but
um that's kind of what really affected
me too yeah and so when you decide to
start the hedge fund you structure in
like a very unique
way talk to us a little bit about the
structure in terms of uh
what you're allowed to do with that
structure yeah so because when i first
saw the hedge fund you know my attorney
asked me
pretty much you know this is important
because when you first set it up that's
when you said that the crown rules
essentially
and you know my attorney asked me like
hey you know do you want to be able to
long and short i'm like sure why not you
know
and then like i also asked for very
specific things back then that nobody
else asked for for example i wanted to
run masternodes
back in 2017 um you know i saw a lot of
potential
where some running nodes would pay five
percent six percent seven percent
sometimes twenty percent right like in
the early days in the first year we ran
nodes on stuff like horizon on v chain
on um uh nim that was like poi
um there's many different um chains that
we run nodes on and the interesting
thing come out of that is that
in my paperwork i'm allowed to stake i'm
allowed to run nodes and stuff like that
which you know now staking is hot now
yield farming is hot right but like i
was kind of like yield farming in the
early days
before yield farming was really like
even the term are popular in fact that
was way more technical you know you had
to actually work with the clients and
set it all up
yeah and so when you think about crypto
i think one of the interesting things is
you kind of separate like what
mainstream audience knows this crypto
and then like what the real
industry is so maybe let's first just
start with like what do you think the
mainstream audience sees as
uh the crypto industry yeah like what is
their interface to this
i i feel like first of all the
mainstream loves to forget about crypto
for three years at a time there's like
they have a blackout you know they party
to her their blackout and then they come
back and they got like you know six
months of like
uh let me go all in on this and and look
quite literally with the financials too
they don't invest and then all of a
sudden it's like i missed the last three
years it's time to go all
in where can i get the highest churn i
missed ethereum i missed bitcoin i even
forget about d5
i want the thing that can make me a
thousand x and what that naturally leads
to
is people listening to the wrong people
like you know like
random instagram influencers sometimes
even models now like you know give
crypto a pick crypto advice
and generally lately it's been memes
it's been dogecoin
sheba coin uh safe moon um
so like there's and i always say that
there's the the
innocent uh scams which are like you
know obvious to
anybody with a little bit of intellect
will say okay well dogecoin there's you
know there's infinite inflation
uh it's just the meme okay there you
know you you know what you get into and
then there's the more elaborate you know
i would say dishonest tokens where
there's zero value or cruel like for
example xrp you can hold the xrp token
but it does not give you access to any
value the xrp network accrues
the team owns like you know 60 of the
supply might have changed since then but
um it's highly centralized no governance
rights right so
the and but they have good marketing
department right so there's these tokens
that have
or even cardano so it's cardano's
something i often call out because
it might be good technology at some
point but the truth is that right now
it's worth like 60 70 billion dollars
with more or less an idea small
contracts on cardinal are not launched
until august
so you've nothing being built on cardeno
because it literally cannot be built
and sometimes people say well you know
people didn't believe in tesla earlier
on either and it went up so much but i'm
like
yes but it wasn't worth 70 billion
dollars at the time so like you know
like in there like it's more like a vc
investment yes but vcs don't invest at
70 billion dollars
right so then people invest their money
seeing the price taker
saying oh it's worth a dollar 80 cents
what if it goes to the price of bitcoin
when they don't even understand market
caps so the mass
the masses they just you know they they
follow tick tock they fall influencers
and
their perception of crypto is that
everything is a currency everything is
just like you know
a cryptocurrency everything's the next
bitcoin um and then there's a whole
different world
which is i think you know what a lot of
like the more educated investors in the
space do and like a lot of the crypto
funds
where it's literally two completely
different worlds one investment doj and
sheba and safe moon
and then we have d5 metaverse and so
forth where we look at tokens like you
know maker dao
or you know unit swap wi-fi where you
have protocols that actually make
hundreds of millions of dollars in
income which is ironic because one of
the most common pushback i get from
critics is that they say
these tokens are not backed by anything
it's the bigger fool theory but the
truth is there's so many tokens that
literally make
fun facts so right now maker maker dao
makes like 195 million dollars a year in
profit
deutsche bank makes 680 million dollars
in profit a year
so we're getting close to maker dao with
you know i think a team of you know a
couple of dozen
is making 33 of the profit of deutsche
bank
meanwhile maker dollar has 14 billion
assets dodgeband gets 1.3
trillion in assets so there's real stuff
it's crazy uh what i want to do is let's
first just you have four major themes i
think to your thesis what are those four
themes right so and these themes have
changed the focus on the bear market i
was like very heavy bitcoin because i
figured you know in a bear market you
want to be with hard money right because
that's when
my money well everything else loses
value but i think right now
like both macro and crypto you know
we're in a bull run so generally this is
when i hold much much less bitcoin
and i want to be in growth assets so and
the four themes that i'm currently
allocating to is
one is defy that's the main thesis
because default was the first to have
that killer application that really
product market fit where
you know it's it's harder to sell
something on let's say a virtual game
then you make more interest in with the
bank it's so simple right bank pays you
0.5
we pay 10 easy sold done so d5 is the
biggest branch
um second is the metaverse which you
know can sound very abstract but in
ethereal but
um you know when i well let me finish
first the four and then i'll go against
the metaverse
um third one is d-web which is
decentralizing the web in and of itself
because we can run you know bitcoin
clients and bitcoin exchange we can run
defy
which is all awesome if it's
decentralized in the back end but
if the front ends are still run on
centralized aws servers
um it just takes a press of a button for
some of these sites to get plugged to
get
um what's called geofence and so forth
and then
while they're well highly techy people
can still use them
the average customer will be cut out and
that defeats the purpose of this whole
industry
and the fourth one is privacy because
while bitcoin and ethereum are both
pseudonymous they're not anonymous
which leads to us building like just
this massive public track record where
if i send you money you can now look at
every single transaction i've ever done
in the past
with that wallet um and you know whether
it's regular consumers being able to see
each other's transactions
this whole company's like chain analysis
that literally do for a living to you
know figure all this out and once
governments not once governments already
work with companies like chain analysis
uh we just become so transparent and i
think it's important that we fight that
early on
before it gets too late so what i want
to talk about is with d5 the kind of
first major theme you have
is the business models right so you
already mentioned that uh maker dow
makes
185 million dollars a year um there's
many examples of this
why do people miss what the actual
business model is
and that idea of profit or revenue is it
simply that
these are like decentralized systems and
it's not flowing to like a traditional
centralized p
l in terms of what they're used to
evaluating or what do you see
in terms of why people don't realize
just how big these things are how
profitable they are
i think it's just a lack of education
right now i mean
significantly i i've had meetings back
in 2019 i did tours where i met with um
you know deutsche bank ubs um commerce
but i did like a europe trip and now and
i talked with like you know
the cios of some of these these banks
and the the level of understanding
was even so limited where some of people
in these high offices didn't even know
that bitcoin had a fixed supply so
there there's a lot of room to go and
even now when i have you know
talks you know talks with um you know
qualified clients
and the question they ask is usually
just like bitcoin bitcoin bitcoin
and then the pushback is that you know
even bitcoin
it's not backed by anything like okay
but listen if that's what you're looking
for you should look listen about defy
but then like no no i want to hear about
bitcoin
funny enough uh last week was the first
time when one of those
uh you know one of my older uh clients
uh sent me a message asking me hey are
we in ethereum
so like that's slowly happening but i
think it's you
you know we all use the term orange pill
right your first orange pulse on with
bitcoin
that's the easiest it has such an easy
narrative to sell
then you can go down that route so i
think it's a lack of education but
um that's why some funds like ours you
know specialize and there's more funds
popping up more
not more and more that literally do what
traditional finance used to do
looking at pns looking at book values
looking at revenues and all that
that allows you to make actually
educated decisions when you think about
um those business models is there
something specific that you look for
uh with d5 regardless of where you build
bitcoin ethereum whatever smart contract
platform
uh are you looking for like truly
decentralized systems where they're
sharing uh some of the revenue yeah all
of the revenue
uh are you trying to buy governance
tokens are you trying to buy something
else like just walk through when you
evaluate a project like what are you
looking for
well the biggest question i always ask
and that's what i tell my analysts is
how does this token accrue value
if the answer is it doesn't then i'm not
really interested so for example
you know unit swap is one of the biggest
default protocols it has amazing volumes
to create
i've used as a product but the uniswap
token currently does not generate any
value for the token
because when you make a trade you pay
0.3 percent but that goes to liquidity
providers
it does not go to uni token holders now
there's people arguing well it's a
governance token so they could change
their mind any day and
start charging a fee but i'm not you
know at this point it's already trading
at a 40 billion evaluation
i'm not really waiting for that day
there are plenty of protocols so i can
see very clearly like you know
one of two ways either popular ways are
buy and burn so make maker for example
the profits are used to buy
and burn maker so number one buying
drives price up burning reduces supply
inflationary
explain buy and burn more granularly
so with the way maker works it's like
the biggest decentralized bank
right now they have created for close to
five billion of their own stable
currency right uh die
that's backed by that's over
collateralized by rap bitcoin by
ethereum all kinds of assets so there's
14 billion in assets
backing almost 5 billion in stablecoin
and why do people do this well you have
your bitcoin and you don't want to sell
it you don't want to create a taxable
event
and maybe you have to pay something or
maybe you want to leverage up and buy
more bitcoin right that works too
um so you can push your wrap bitcoin
into maker it gives you out
maybe 50 or 30 percent that some in die
and you can do it with that what you
want then it charges you 5.5
annual stability fee like an interest
rate right um that the maker token
holders get to set right so the actual
bank is fully run by the token holders
which is also fascinating
now when you pay that debt off you say
okay i'm returning my money i'm paying
off the debt
that that interest then is being used to
buy makers so they will put an auction
up they say hey we're looking to buy
maker who wants to sell to us best price
gets it
they have the maker and then they send
it to a burn address meaning a debt
address on the blockchain that nobody's
access to
and it's gone forever from the supply
how do you know that nobody has access
to the address
well you can check usually so a lot of
times you use this your x000 address
where like it's just like the that
edge of the blockchain you can also
check who's the the key holder
got it and so when they send it there by
quote-unquote burning it yeah basically
they're essentially not destroying it
what they're actually doing is they're
losing it intentionally right right
they're sending it somewhere where no
one can access it no matter what happens
and therefore that's quite cool burning
it
and so if you keep track of this people
understand what's been burnt first not
burnt
and then therefore that should lead to
um
right yeah so you've got deflation i
mean that's what makes bitcoin great too
right you have like the fixed supply
schedule
so with some of these protocols you
might even have a deflationary cycle
so does buy and burn only work when
there's a fixed supply uh
no so there's protocols that have
inflation and like you know they have an
annual mint and an annual burn now the
goal of course is to make sure that the
burn is higher than the mint
so it could be that the dow for example
does an annual mint which allows them to
run operations so for example i said on
the enzyme console so i'm on the dial
for one protocol enzyme
and we have an annual mint so we have
300 000 mlm that we can
use to you know pay developers you know
all kinds of stuff
at the same time when people use the
protocol it generates fees that are then
burned
so currently there's a higher mint than
a burn but the goal over the years is of
course
invest that money well enough with the
earnings
become bigger and bigger and bigger and
can actually be larger than that
and why buy and burn versus distribute
let's say for example transaction fees
or revenue or anything to these token
holders like from a business model
decision standpoint there's it's kind of
something like share buybacks right
stock buybacks um
the the the idea that the reason i
personally like buy and burn better is
because it doesn't cause a taxable event
if you distribute if you give somebody
mistaking returns all you're doing is
creating a taxable event this is why i'm
a huge opponent to
inflation-based staking returns it's one
of the biggest jokes in the industry
honestly that
um people brag let's focus on cardinal
people brag about oh i'm making you know
five percent 10
15 interest on my card and i'm like you
know where that comes from
they're printing new cardona tokens so
your buying power
is being decreased you're earning
rewards that then per irs you have to
pay taxes on because they are you know
it's a fiat currency yeah right it's the
whole idea that
yes i'm giving you more of the currency
or token that you hold
but at the same time the ones that
you're holding are going down in value
because it's inflationary
right and so there's no difference
between the federal reserve doing this
or
a crypto project not any specific one
but just they're doing it
now when they do that is it fair to
assume that that's like a marketing cost
so they're doing this to acquire users
yeah or is this something else that
they're doing in terms of creating
new currency to then distribute to
people and even though those people see
it as quote unquote yield
it's not technically yield generated
from lending it's yield literally
generated by new tokens that are minted
by the treasury
it's funny because like i i'm a very
conservative guy when it comes to like
that investing aspect and i love
deflation or tokens but i kind of had to
learn my lesson during
d5 summer as we call it last year where
there was a lot of these projects having
insane inflation rates they had like 800
inflation rate they had like you know
thousand percent and so forth like just
mass huge mints
and i was like that we call it
ponzinomics you know because you know
you're paying somebody
to provide liquidity but that that's
obviously not going to work out long
term
um but the ironies it did work out for
many of them where i was just shocked
because you know it was
and i i ended up writing an article
about what i said you know what what
this did
what what looked so um you know
scammy at first was actually the thing
that solved the chicken and the egg
problem because when it comes to d5 you
know
you can't have users without liquidity
but also nobody wants to provide
liquidity if there's no users
so all of a sudden you know you just
like front loaded incentives
to the liquidity providers so there's a
ton of liquidity and then all of a
sudden you
realize well it's just as easy now to
trade on unit swap as it is on binance
or maybe even better
and that's that's what really like
that's where d5 kind of blew up because
all of a sudden people realized well
these are fully flushed liquid markets
where i can get
leverage out i can trade anything i want
in fact there was more
every token on ethereum it's listed on
uniswap unlike binance um
so even though like it was sketchy at
first to me i realized wait this is
actually what
that's what silicon valley's been doing
for years they they run at a loss
in the first few years to get to that
tipping point to get you know customer
question get to traction
and then you can always dial it down and
i've seen that with a few project
balancer for example i mean balance had
increa
incredible inflation where they just you
know gave out free battle tokens to
anybody who provided liquidity even like
teams would literally create their own
tokens
matched against ethereum or something
and get ton of rewards
for their own token you know which they
create out of thin air but hey at the
end of the day it's become one of the
most highly liquid
platforms yeah when you think about uh
other things to stay away from as you
evaluate projects is there anything else
that kind of sticks out to you you
mentioned ponzinomics but like is there
anything else that you think is
a red flag or things that you actively
avoid
a few things well first when it comes to
things like yield i always love to ask
where does that yield come from right so
i mistaken returns are great especially
if they come from earnings so for
example terra luna
um was something i paid attention to in
august already because i've realized oh
there's like a 1.5 million users in
south korea
and they are actually like the the nine
percent staking returns they pay
they're coming from transaction fees so
like people are actually paying that so
awesome
but if i see a thousand percent api
coming from i'm like where does it come
from
inflation at some point there will be
rock pool right so
um so and what is a rug oh yeah a rock
pool well if you stand on a rocket so it
pulls the rug underneath your feet you
know
you fall in your face um so that usually
means that either early investors or
team members
are essentially dumping uh you know they
they create enough momentum get the
price up get the price upgrade price up
and then at some point they can either
remove liquidity from unit swap
or dump it all if somebody else provides
liquidity and then you're stuck holding
it back with
zero liquidity in the markets so that's
something else to look out for is like
when you get into a project especially
when you think oh i'm early
look at their order books like how many
people provide liquidity how much
liquidity is there can you even get out
if you wanted to um so i think in
general like for new retail investors
getting into this market i always say
like you know
first of all not financial advice but
like start with bitcoin and ethereum and
then if you want to get fancy maybe add
the d5 pulse index so
you're indexing into the d5 and then
just like again always walk your way
from like top market cap down
rather and but not in terms of investing
but in terms of research like
try to actually understand what these
projects are doing um i think
decentralization is just as important
that the teams don't own that much i
don't think teams should own more than
i mean 25 is already a lot i think i
don't think teams should own more than
20
of token supply because then it becomes
and one of the biggest red flags too
is that there shouldn't be a centralized
entity
behind a token project because then i'm
asking what what's the focus there's a
concept of interest
here prime example is ripple labs you
know are you trying to provide
value for ripple apps which they're
trying to ipo or you're trying to
provide that value for ripple the token
so i really want teams where their only
incentive is a token itself because
ultimately look everybody's trying to
make money so they'll find a way somehow
down the road to bring value cruel back
to that token
what's up guys before we continue with
this interview i want to quickly talk
about our sponsor
kraken kraken's one of the most
established and secure places to buy
cryptocurrencies on the internet
they've been at the forefront of the
bitcoin and blockchain revolution
for over 10 years their mission is to
bring crypto to the masses so whether
you're an og
or this is your first trade kraken has
all of the tools that you need to
achieve financial freedom
with more than 60 cryptocurrencies
available you can invest in
all of the most popular projects in the
industry including bitcoin
ethereum and many many more kraken also
provides in-depth articles
and guides on every single asset that
they list so you can get up to speed
quickly and make smarter investment
decisions
visit kraken.com bang bang to get
started today
again that's kraken.com bang bang
alright let's get back into this
interview i hope you're enjoying it
when you think of a fair launch what is
that
right so that's something that people
hear all the time as opposed to more
um kind of align incentives and make
sure that it solves some of the problems
you're talking about here but what
exactly is the fair launch fair launch
is trying to avoid exactly that the team
the team allocation
um the one of the first ones was wi-fi
you know where essentially
um by contributing to the project
you can earn like pretty much once it
was announced anybody can earn these
tokens
at the same rate the founders can right
so there's nobody pre-mining it
and in pre-mine is sometimes misused
well prime can sometimes be that you
launch
a project stealth mode you're the only
one mining it and that's why you're
getting all the tokens
or it could be free mine also is used
when you say like hey at ico we get 20
so fair launches the whole idea is that
we find a more fair way where the team
has no advantage over community members
and rather everybody earns tokens so how
does it like structurally work though
fair launch well so for example let's
say we have um let's say you and i start
a new uh
amm a new automated market make or
lending protocol right
and we say hey um we're not taking any
coins from the beginning instead
we're using all the tokens for liquidity
incentives
so if you and i want to earn tokens we
have to provide liquidity just like
everybody else
so that every single token is you know
earned through official channels there's
no backdoor deals there's no private
sales there's no advisory contracts
there's no team
but rather it's very clear where you
know everybody else in the room has the
same
chances of participating like you and i
do
because you know the whole idea of
decentralization is to you know remove a
lot of these gatekeepers but
um you know crypto is seeing some of
this come back right
unfortunately because of the sec right
so the sec shut down icos because of all
the scams that were happening
what's the end result we've got a ton of
private sales where you know it's only
insiders being able to get into rounds
um because you know teams aren't able to
sell
sell publicly anymore is the fair launch
like okay with the sec because they're
not actually selling anything
to the public for investment so
therefore uh it
isn't considered like a security and
it's completely different thing or how
does icon comment because i don't think
they've commented yet so like the fair
launch is not something they've looked
at but at the end of the day since
they're not selling anything and this is
they're not fundraising right they're
not fundraising
yeah but and that's also like a big
shift i see um
i i made the prediction i said i think
by 2030 or 2025
um there will be more dows decentralized
autonomous organizations
than there will be llc's i think a lot
of startups in the future they'll just
launch us dows
where you know they can sell their dial
token memberships and then the money
doesn't go into their bank account it
goes into the dow
treasury which is a multi-sig wallet
where you know a few shareholders or
everybody in the dow has voting rights
over and
that literally just takes out of the
jurisdiction of the government there's
really not that much you can do of
course
the government can always do something
but at the end of the day um i think
it's still a very very gray space that's
what exactly is the dao explain it to
people so a dao
is kind of like a decentralized llc if
you want that has
no that's everywhere and nowhere the
same time so there's no jurisdiction
really
uh what it does is essentially based on
a smart contract where let's say
you me and let's say three friends we
want to start a company
um what we can do is you know set up a
smart contract where there's five down
membership tokens
each of us gets a down membership token
and then in order to pass votes we can
use tools like you know gnosis safe or
aragon and to pass a vote we can make
the rules the beginning you know do we
need super majority do we need unanimous
consent whatever
three people vote for something let's
say we say we want to
send a thousand eth that's a lot
nowadays but anyway we want to send a
thousand eighth
to another wallet well three of us voted
proof
and the money moves so this way we can
really um decentralize and automate
treasury management for example we can
automate you know decision making
protocol upgrades
um and that's how a lot of teams are now
running and i think every team should be
run we
should be ran with a dow which by you
know back in 2017 we didn't have that
now
most projects do you know unit swap is
token based voting maker is in the name
maker dao is token based voting
um enzyme like the one i'm in it's more
like an elected version where we have a
council people elect the council and the
council has these
voting tokens where we make the
decisions and we can be vetoed off the
council again
so which is also interesting because the
whole crypto space is kind of like a
hyper speed
re-exploring governance really you know
like we're going through thousands of
years and figuring out what is the best
system
because one token one vote can lead to
plutocracy
one vault one wallet one vote can lead
to sybil attacks where you i just make a
thousand wallets you know on a boat
um so then what's the solution you know
and
i don't think with the answer to that
yet one thing before we move on to the
metaverse
is uh automated market makers uh explain
how these work for people who don't
understand
so you know with with liquid
with dexas with descent decentralized
exchanges it was always the problem when
you have the order book model you know
the order book model that you used to
from coinbase from binance where you see
like
price and how much is their price how
much is there um
it's very hard to create good liquidity
so what automated market makes real
quick just start interrupt but uh
basically because uh you have buyers and
sellers or bid
and ask right you need people to set
limit orders right and what people are
essentially doing
is you may put something forward at 200
i may put
for that i'm willing to sell it at uh
220
and then literally we've got to continue
until somebody moves in either direction
until we get a match
and then that's how the order book
matches that's where the actual
transaction
yeah and maybe sometimes you're you know
especially because you know
especially in the theorem right now it's
expensive to do transactions so imagine
you have to change your order
every single time the market moves so
what and those
orders end up being a transaction fee
every time
well actually when you with crx when you
set the limit order you just sign it
it's actually free but then whoever
takes it
will have to buy into it and it costs
something but what the amms did
essentially is you said hey instead of
us
like getting attracting all these people
that choose individual prices where they
put their limit or is that like it's
going to take too long again the goal
was to solve the chicken the egg problem
and just get liquidity
so i think unisport was the first to do
it although i think they leaned on
bancor where you say hey we need
all we need is two assets uh you know
btc usd
right so let's say you've wrapped
bitcoin and usdc
so you stuff literally let's say you
have a hundred thousand bitcoin a
hundred thousand dollars in cash
you put it into the pool and then the
pool has a 50 50 weighing so the goal is
that the pool
always has 50 50 of both assets
so let's say somebody goes ahead and
says hey i'm going to buy
a thousand dollars of bitcoin what
happens well now there's a hundred
thousand
one hundred and one thousand dollars in
usdc in there
and technically there's only 99 000 in
bitcoin so what has to happen
the price of bitcoin will for that amm
go up enough where it's worth 100 1 000.
so each amm so to say has its own price
and the price is always determined by
the the peg ratio so say that's always
50 50. it basically auto
it all the balances and the reason why
it does that and how it does that is it
basically is eliciting
liquidity or really kicking liquidity
out in some cases right
and it's able to actually get back to
that right so you always take from one
side of the pool
right so there's just money sitting on
both sides and if you want to buy or
sell you take from each either side
and that that also leads to like it
automatically calculates how much market
impact you have because that means
i can't buy all the hundred thousand
bitcoin for the current price no for me
to buy
a hundred thousand bitcoin uh hundred
thousand dollars of the bitcoin would
really
you know drop the price bitcoin up so
much because whatever's left has to be
worth all the cash on the other side
so when that occurs if i'm the one who's
providing liquidity what do i get
uh depending on the platform so like on
balancer for example you earn you can
you can set your own fee so for example
i run several bouncer pools
and i can charge whatever one whatever
sometimes point five sometimes six
percent so like there's some
less liquid all coins where nobody's
providing the query but i say hey i
believe in them they're solid
you know so i'm taking that risk that if
they go to zero of course i lose money
on both sides
right but i say hey because nobody else
providing liquidity let me charge five
percent six percent
and everybody's every time somebody
trades i make five or six percent on
that
um and how much volume don't say one of
the names but just like how much volume
on these kind of more illiquid assets is
there in a given day or a week
i mean the apy can turn into you know
a hundred percent 150 a year yeah
so it's not necessarily uh
huge volume no right and it's not also
uh
really really frequent trading but it's
just because you've got to set up five
or six percent it can
it adds up it adds up right and and so
and then so and
and that's on balancer where you can set
your own rates on unit swap the base
rate is always point three percent
um so it's always point three percent on
unit swap and then sometimes there's
again
incentives like balance it gives you
battle tokens other exchanges give you
you know b and t gives you b t
tokens and so forth to further
incentivize it
what's the metaverse that's one of your
big uh what one of your big kind of
themes or thesis
what is that so back in 2019 i did you
know i did some
tours been in bear market a lot more
time so i wanted to like kind of like
spread the gospel of bitcoin you know
and one of the questions i used to ask
is you know how much time do you spend
online
well let me ask you how much time do you
spend online too much too much okay
in hours what do you think yeah uh a day
i don't know between my phone and
computer six seven hours eight hours
all right we'll set up for eight and
let's assume you sleep eight hours i
know you sleep way less probably but
um that means it'll be a half a day and
the truth like when i ask this usually
like even like
um you know gen z or young millennials
the numbers even higher
so the truth is most of us spend 50 to
75
of our waking hours in the digital world
so that doesn't stand to reason that
we would need a digital form of money
okay bitcoin
that we need digital infrastructures
like for example financial
infrastructures like d5 then we need
digital governance
dows and also and then you get to this
point we say well if we
have all of this that's digital we kind
of approach a point where the digital
reality really because you we spent so
much time online where
our digital identity is almost as big if
not bigger
than our base reality sounds weird but i
realized if the first time really hard
when i got hacked one time
back in 2018 i was talking about like
target crypto hacking attack
sim swap and everything and and when i
lost all my online profiles my emails
everything i was like wow i'm so cut off
from the world
i don't even you know i don't even know
how to reach people because like i don't
even have my mom's email memorized now
so and so what the metaverse
is kind of getting into is that hey
there is
there's more than base reality right
we're gonna have we can have multiple
identities and the first
iteration of that has always been gaming
right so people like the gaming issue is
huge it blew up during covet
and so we've seen this already 10 years
ago with second life for example where
second life
made i think the number was 500 million
that had a 500 million dollars a year
gdp
so digital goods have real value
people value the time they spend online
how they spend time online
what they're wearing in the digital
world so and i always say that for
example facebook and instagram and so
forth
our form of virtual reality just really
shitty ui right so
as we go into the future and these ui
zooxes become better
um we're gonna have probably like
digital avatars just like with a
metamask wall to login you're gonna have
a digital avatar
and that's what for example nfts also
start having value
where you say hey people are willing to
pay thousands of dollars for gucci or
for rolex
and so forth so why wouldn't they do
that when
in the location they spent 75 of the day
so when i think of the metaverse uh i
think most people think of like ready
player one
right like hey i put on a headset and i
go into this like super virtual world
whatever
your argument is basically rather than
the headset the portal is either the
phone or the computer
you're going into the world you're
playing this thing and
it works right and you and i connected
in the quote-unquote metaverse from the
digital world right then we bring it
into the physical world
and so how much of this is um kind of
evolutionary from where we already are
with traditional technology like the
googles the facebooks the
uh instagrams to no actually it's gonna
be way more on the other end of the
spectrum and the super kind of
uh extreme example of the ready player
one or kind of what a meta covan might
agree with in terms of like uh digital
museums or virtual museums and stuff
like that like
are we headed on either end of the
extreme or maybe in the middle
like just like where do you think we're
going well that's why i approach usually
like this because like when i go with
ready play i want people think oh that's
so far out there that's not gonna happen
in my lifetime and i'm like no like
think 20 years back like even when i
grew up like we used to run in the
garden you know like we we didn't have
smartphones smartphones came out i'm
like you know oh wait
right so the we are already this
trajectory and this the the versions we
live in now where that's like
the facebook instagrams the video games
it's just an early duration like i said
the ui ux isn't that great but
give it five years and it might look
like ready player one
um and i just left my train of thought
uh in terms of the extremes are we going
to the end of
the extreme of like ready player one is
it more like the instagram facebooks
than just there's an evolutionary
approach
or is it somewhere in between well i
think it's well it's it's
the end game will be ready player one
with like headsets or no i mean i think
the the headset
that's funny because like they still
lean on like old tech i mean in the
future you might have you know if you've
ever seen um
black mirror you know they've this
little thing that they put there you
might have lenses you might have print
computer interfaces
all you know all that's going to be
there i i can't imagine that we have
like all these virtual worlds but we
still use old clunky headsets
i uh i saw a video online recently of
somebody who it looked like they kind of
put on glasses
and they were trying to simulate like
this virtual world and literally
they were walking in i think it was a
bus or a train and they were kind of
walking through the aisle and their
seats on both sides
and literally there was like screens
popping up and seen that video yeah and
there was
kind of blinking lights and all this
stuff and it kind of uh in some crazy
way reminded me of like a tokyo arcade
almost right like you know there's like
black like flashing lights and bright
colors and like all stuff
and uh the person i saw shared it was
like i do not want this world
right right of like oh my god this is
like you know literally mental overload
uh is that what it's like or is there
some like very watered-down version that
might be more like augmented reality
type stuff
not necessarily like this complete
virtual world where everything's
gamified and there's like points popping
up and
all this craziness or you don't know i
well i mean
to an extent i think we might look at
this right now and say like oh this is
something i don't want
um but i think a lot of stuff we have
nowadays our grandparents would have
said like oh that's something we don't
want that's like that's
everything's bad right so and
i think this the verse the video that
you describe is maybe a future where
it's
centralized and that's why i think it's
so so important that that the metaverse
has a decentralized space infrastructure
because who is the biggest vr producer
right now
it's facebook oculus right and then also
you've got htc vive
right do you really want um the
infrastructure of the digital world to
be in the hand of facebook
at least in my opinion no all right ux
google facebook
i think most people would say that right
and just from a pure just no one company
should have all the power
absolutely yeah and so that becomes
scary because you know
facebook the biggest complaint about
facebook is you know the advertising you
know that they target advertising
now what if right now we're not actually
sitting here
but you and i are at home and we have an
oculus headset on or oculus chip in our
head or something like that
and really you know maybe there's a
print on your
on your shirt that's not actually there
but facebook projection projected there
because they can
right because they literally own the
digital world so
you know when you understand that as i
said with that initial question how much
time do we spend online
the digital world is will literally be
more valuable
than the base reality because we spend
so much time because it's global it's
borderless
then who's going to own that it can't be
private entities you have to have
you have to set up decentralized
infrastructure on which that can be
built so that means
um decentralized identity standards
right decentralized um
just a rule like for example
decentraland was one of the first uh
products in the space where they created
a decentralized
world and in that world you have to set
up your own rules you know like how
because
ultimately people think well if it's a
game you can have infinite items
but then if everything is infinite
there's people that people love a
competitive world
there has to be rules so for example the
way engine which is one of
those projects goes about is that any
time you mint an in-game item you have
to what's the word
like pretty much mold engine tokens into
it so that way like there's a cost
to producing in-game items um
it's like figuring more of that out so
this is like one of the more like you
know d5 is more mainstream now but like
metaverse is definitely more on the
cutting edge
it takes a lot of time to just like wrap
your head around you know
first of all where's this world going
how
will such a digital world experientially
feel like and what will be important we
see the first iteration of that now with
like nfts right but people
because people can easily wrap the head
around i can hang it on the wall it's
like a picture
i own it great but in the future you
know nfts go way beyond just being a
picture
it can any item like this table can be
an nft
in in your virtual world that you pay
for just like a normal table why
again because we spent most of our time
in the digital world and i think a time
like covert
highlighted it more than ever where
we're all stuck at home
and now imagine if the the the you know
the ui the ux was amazing and like
just like really you can actually feel
maybe whole body suits right
at that point i think that's a time when
we can actually replace it
i know that sounds very far out on the
spectrum but if i've learned anything
it's like technology comes way faster
than we think
yeah of course yeah what do you think is
the biggest fear that you have around
the metaverse
uh centralization central is it being
being in the hands of private entities
and that goes a step further too
even if we decentralize and has uh
decentralized governance
you don't want let's say like let's say
facebook invests is
let's say facebook's the lead investor
or even at reason i mean like i think
andreas has
got an intention for whatever right but
i don't want a single entity having
let's say 20 of the tokens or like the
voting rights
over literally like the laws of nature
of the digital world
essentially so i think it's just very
important that right now we're building
that base infrastructure on which
everything will be built because
and that's this is why it's so unusual
because and it's unlike
with d5 i look at you know balance
sheets p l's easy to understand
here it's really more so we're literally
rebuilding the entire reality entire
world from the ground up
and on the one hand yeah you want it to
be value accruing by the same time it
also shouldn't turn into just you know
where the early investors literally
owned the entire world
so uh yeah it's a lot more abstract but
at the same time
it will likely be bigger than anything
else because it literally
the size of the metaverse is multiples
of the entire gdp of the entire world
right now because we'll have likely
higher populations
and um everybody will participate who's
going to make the laws in the metaverse
i think daos will decide that right so
and i i think it's very possible and
this is where
you know crypto such a cool early
ecosystem of that because when we talk
about
having diff different avatars different
identities look at
crypto twitter where you have real
people with cartoon character
personalities with hundreds of thousands
of followers that people treat like
they're real
you know you've got the crypto dog
you've got the this and that right
and that's essentially like like again
shitty ui but it's
that's an early implementation of the
metaverse
and and then we can decide you know like
within that land whether it's
infinite or restricted um you have to
centralize autonomous organizations that
make rules within the boundary and then
you can always
we use the term rage quit if you say hey
i don't agree with the terms of the dao
you can always leave it and take your
assets with you um
finding your home when you talk about
centralization i know that two other
themes are the decentralized web or
d-web
uh and privacy how do those themes play
into this
right so with the web i always explain
very simply where i say we are
you know a lot of people started using
unit swap a lot of people started using
all these default protocols and while
they're decentralized on
the back end so to say you know like yes
it's run on ethereum but all the front
and clients they're run
on aws they're all run on you know some
kind of centralized form
where like the platform and that means
that if the government wakes up tomorrow
and says hey
we don't want to allow defy now granted
they can't shut down ethereum they can't
shut down the new subcode so that's true
but they could you know ban the front
ends take them
make them unavailable in the us
implement geofencing so for example we
actually saw this today where
uh on ave they had a restricted aml kyc
pool that apparently is only for
institutional clients right
so is that a good thing or a bad thing i
think it's both i mean the good thing is
there's institutions that actually start
allocating to d5 you know like alec into
default pools which is fascinating that
there's you know
bigger institutions the bad thing is
that like i mean
it lays the groundwork that that might
be happening at
some more scale in the future whether
it's in the u.s some other country i
mean i'm sure there will be other
countries that will
reach out to these teams and say hey um
which is why it's important these teams
are decentralized because
i always say if you're decentralized
there's there's a lot less doors you can
knock on
who who's story going to knock on if
there's no llc if there's no
incorporation
right but if it's a dao it's like
everybody can click pleat the fifth so
for example on
you know well on some dials that i'm
involved in i just was scared
um you know we're all like contractors
we're all like arm's length distance
where it's like there's really nobody
that really
like it's owned by everybody but nobody
so
with the with d-web the idea is that you
also then decentralize
the front-end so meaning what if we have
decentralized broadband what if we have
decentralized
hosting decentralized dns having all
these different parts that are part of
the internet experience
and decentralize them so that no
centralized authority
can um first of all take them down but
also then from a security perspective
where like
you actually own your data that's on the
aws kind of disappear
or all the dns attacks that have been
happening you know just like not your
keys on your crypto well not your not
your domain keys not your domain right
it's kind of similar um so moving that
entire internet experience but making
fully decentralized and you know early
implementation of that you know stuff
like you know whether it's file coin cya
coin where
you know people um whole like store
data on their computers just like miners
my bitcoin and they're being rewarded
in that native asset for it and then you
can pay people a native asset in order
to have it stored
for example what about privacy you keep
talking about uh
kind of topics that relate to privacy
but we haven't dug deep there like
what is the fascination with privacy
well well you know at first when you
start using bitcoin ethereum you think
oh this is private i'm anonymous i can
do whatever i want
but you know the more time you spend
using crypto the more you realize that
no you're actually really transparent
because while it's not anonymous it's
pseudonymous and while if you have
good privacy hygiene so to say and you
set up a new wallet every time you do
something
that's creating all but ultimately first
of all even normal people
can track what you're doing so like if
you sent me money i can i now have your
public key whether it's bitcoin ethereum
i now have a public key
i can go on the blockchain.com or i can
go you know
or to ether scan and i find out okay
where else have you sent money well how
much are you sending and while i don't
know necessarily who you're sending it
to
i do get some information which is
almost like any time you know i swipe my
card or restaurant you get my bank
statement which is wild
um and that's on the harmless side but
then on the more intense side there's
whole firms like chain analysis
whose whole job it is to you know really
analyze the blockchain and figure out
whose wall belongs to whom
and they're playing a massive game of
puzzle where you know
today they might have you know let's say
if it's a big map like in a video game
you know
they might have like 20 figured out but
given enough time enough progress and
enough kyc transactions where people
like kind of like show their cards
you know in some some time in the future
it's almost all going to be public
uh and that needs to change so in order
to maintain privacy you know there's a
few tools either having
native private uh blockchains um and
again i think that's more contrarian
takes so like we don't allocate a lot to
that but you know
whether that's you know cash for example
is pretty much a bitcoin fork same
supply schedule
but it's based on your knowledge proofs
uh so it's fully private
um or in terms of ethereum you've got
secret network formerly called enigma
which does like smart contracts
but fully private so then you also have
like the
secret c5 secret finance which is um uh
like d5 but fully private so that way
you can't track the trades you make
publicly
um and then or if you want to keep it
native on bitcoin or ethereum you know
there's almost always
some layer two solution like um you know
in a theorem you've got whether it's
tornado
cache where you can like you know uh
it's a mixer like i sent
i sent in 10 ethereum and a thousand
other people also nintendo ethereum
they got all mixed up and they come out
on the other side nobody knows where it
came from
if the sample size is that legal that is
legal um
so the good thing is with these
platforms is they do give you the keys
to proof origination so like if i get
audited
i i have the ability to show where it
came from
so but it's in my uh you know it's my
hands
got it so basically nobody can know it
unless i tell them
who it is correct and so somebody comes
and asks me and it's in my best interest
to tell them i can
correct you still have the ability to
which is important because otherwise you
know you can
you know let's say there was some
terrorist organization like
using that that same pool you don't want
to get tied to that you're like hey it
wasn't me
shows the you know you can prove the
transaction okay i'm fine um
you know because you know the sad thing
with crypto is that unfortunately all
too many times people love to use the
label of like you know whether it's like
money laundering or terrorist financing
and that's why crypto bitcoin should die
from everything
everything is evil but you know there's
been studies made on this and probably
know the numbers but and i do you know
it's
less than like one percent i mean it's a
fraction it's a tiny tiny amount
um when compared to fiat money or gold
or paintings you know it's it doesn't
even
stack up um so a lot of times people try
to use that as a weapon against crypto
but i i don't think that means that we
kind of privacy because people always
say like hey
uh you know oh you only need privacy
trying to hide something you know and i
think somebody said um
somebody made the the metaphor once like
you know did you close the shower
curtain because you're hiding something
i mean like you know like yeah
you still want you know with windows you
won't have clients you want to be able
like
not because you're killing somebody
inside the house but maybe you want to
close the blinds
right so and and i think some level
privacy is just
natural human right and because at the
end of the day
it also makes us vulnerable you know if
let's say for example you do pay for
your coffee
with bitcoin do you really want
everybody to know like what coffee shop
you buy bitcoin at at what time now they
can track your
your whole day so any anyway like
privacy is just something that's
unexplored because the only people aware
of the lack thereof
are the people actually using it um so
again this is something i think to be
early on where we say okay how can we
you know maintain some level of security
where we for example we don't
necessarily have to go to layer two
maybe it's just like an actual native
upgrade
or um for example in the sense that we
can prove
that we would we didn't do anything
illegal like with tornado
what is some of the stuff that nobody's
talking about yet but you're like hey
five years from now this is gonna be
really really important but nobody
realizes it yet
i mean until recently i would have said
metaverse and now it's been popping up
because nfts got hot and now there's a
clubhouse room talk about metaverse but
you know we
funny enough we know we made our most
recent we we we added metaverse to the
deck like a year ago
um in fact back even two years ago we
just called it the decentralized gaming
um because i think you know five years
from now um
that digital economy will be i mean i i
make the comparison that i think d5 will
be bigger than the nasdaq by 2025.
um i would say the metaverse is has that
i mean that's aggressive but i would say
the metaverse probably has a bigger gdp
than the us by 2035.
2035 so if i was going to say 2030 but
that sounded too ambitious but
usually it's probably earlier you know
um because because ultimately
there's already now like really
fascinating examples where the people
for some of the philippines they
literally
played this thing whole idea of like
play to earn where people play these
decentralized games like axes infinity
and they're earning enough money to
literally pay for their mortgages to pay
for their life
um which is fascinating when you can
like really just distribute these games
so you can decentralize a lot of this
online experience
and make that a way to generate income
yeah i mean it replaces the whole idea
of the government needing to support you
you can still work regardless as long as
you have an internet connection
yeah right uh i asked her the same three
questions before we finish up you could
ask me one
first most important book
i'm going to be go follow with taran
here uh atlas shrugged
why uh so funny enough i've read it
during the the pandemic i finished it so
i read two books during the pandemic i
think one of them
actually came from you which was um
atlas shrugged and second one was the
fourth training
i read about your newsletter and those
two books at that point in time which is
extremely impactful
because so much of that is playing out
in real time
you know an atlas struck that talks a
lot about the politicians
that you know use the common good as an
excuse to alienate a lot of the
producers
right and then you ask well are you
actually i think it was a quote by or um
by um
wells uh so the guy that wrote 1984
where he said you know a lot of times
that it's not the hate of the rich um no
no
it's not the love of the poor it's the
hate of the rich that motivates a lot of
that
right and so seeing this is reading both
those books for turning where people
kind of like to you know
turn weak and people start turning into
like you know the the conflict the
cultural conflicts get exacerbated you
know
and that comes really played out with
cobit and then also atlas struck where i
saw
elon musk leave california right there's
this hole where they try to shut down
his factory i'm like
this is straight up from the book where
they try to shut down hand careers
factories
you almost like no i'll stay on the
floor off my factory if anybody gets
arrested it's me
right and seeing that play out and
there's like i'm out going to texas
we're going to miami going to florida so
i think
in the current day and age i think both
those books are really important
to read and yeah sleep schedule
from our friends over at eight sleep
they have a thermo-regulated bed
really hot really cold in miami when it
gets hot obviously having a cold bed is
great and helps you sleep deeper
i sleep like five six hours and i sleep
like eight or nine what's your sleep
schedule
i used to be horrible with sleep
schedules i used to sleep like you know
five hours i've been taking it serious
lately
i mean i'm because i train every morning
at 8am so i try to be
in bed by like you know 11 or midnight
and then do get up at seven so like
eight hours
right because i've i've learned to
optimize the hours i'm awake not the
hours when i'm asleep
uh because it you know what do we get
paid for having a sharp mind being able
to like make the important decisions
um and you lose that if you're always
running on e yeah
i couldn't agree more i am a full-on
convert
uh last question is aliens are you a
believer or a non-believer
i think i'm a believer the universe is
too large it's statistically probable
almost that we're alone
yeah they might have we are alone or not
alone it's statistically improbable that
we're alone
oh impossible improbable correct so
there's
and i don't think they'll probably look
like the way we think they do they're
not little green men no they're probably
not little green man well here's the
thing there's two options either
they're dumber than us and we just find
like you know little animals and we
think they're cute but they're also
intelligent life
or they're way smarter than us they
already know about us
you know and you know look at these
fools look at these fools like
arguing with themselves two-party system
and
you get spf money you get asked me one
question to finish up what do you got
for me
um what are you most bullish about about
the crypt industry
for the next five years i think the
number one missed price thing in the
entire market mispriced
is d5 built on top of bitcoin uh
and d5 meaning decentralized finance
started with bitcoin itself
decentralized money now there's
decentralized exchanges decentralized
lending all this you know a lot of stuff
we've been talking about it's built on
all kinds of different
technological foundations right um and
so this idea of like almost automated
finance is kind of how i
talk about it but specifically built on
top of bitcoin in a way that vertically
integrates the decentralized financial
applications with the decentralized
money
i think everyone wrote off right
everyone said hey uh you can't do smart
contracts on bitcoin let's go build it
also that's why ethereum was started
many other smart contract platforms
there's absolutely market value being
created there right there's you know i
don't know
at this point literally tens of billions
of dollars locked in total value
uh there's all sorts of uh people coming
in using this stuff we just talked about
abe
and all stuff uh but i think a mispriced
part of the market
is that actually now that there's smart
contracts on top of bitcoin uh there's
decentralized financial applications uh
happening on bitcoin etc
uh there's just a lot of opportunity
there that people kind of overlooked
and so that is exciting because it
usually means there's asymmetry there
right and so i'm spending a lot of time
kind of trying to figure out
what's real what's not and kind of what
the the potential value proposition is
but that's probably
one area of many that i think is really
interesting awesome
all right where can people find you on
the internet uh well for crypto stuff
you know always twitter
at felix or hartman and i'm actually one
of the few crypto people that's also
very active on instagram so instagram
felix underscore hartman i do like you
know what live streams they're like
explaining a lot of stuff kind of like
we talked here
awesome yeah so twitter and instagram
yep awesome
listen thank you so much for doing this
i'm glad you're here now in miami and
we'll have to do it again
i appreciate you thank you